what are the dangers of backbiting and
gossip mongering during the month of
Ramadan one of the major sins in Islam
it is slandering and backbiting and
Allah says in the Quran in Surah humza
chapter number 104 verse Number
One V to every kind of back biter and
slanderer that you have to woe to
everyone who back bites and sers and
Allah says in the Quran in Surah huat
chapter number 49 verse number 12 that
avoid suspicion because sometimes
suspicion is a sin do not speak ill
about anyone behind the
back are you ready to eat the meat of
your dead brother and Allah continu on
saying that n you would abort it here
Allah gives the example that a person
who back bites it is as though he's
eating his own brother now eating the
meat of your own brother is Haram and
further it says eating dead meat eating
dead meat is also Haram so if you
backbite you're committing a double sin
not only eating the meat of a brother
eating the Flesh of your dead brother so
it is a very grave sin and our beloved
Prophet M wasallam said it's mentioned
in s Muslim why number four Hadith
number
6265 where Prophet malli wasallam asked
the sahabas that do you know what is
backbiting they say that the messenger
of Allah knows the best so prophet
says that if a person speaks about
somebody else behind his back which he
would not have liked that is called as
backbiting speaking about somebody
behind his back which the person would
not like is called as backbiting so one
of the sahaba he asked that oh Prophet
what if the thing has spoken is the
truth or the fault which I mentioned
does exist in the person so the prophet
said that if what you have spoken is the
truth and the fault does exist it is
called as backbiting otherwise it's
called as slandering so backbiting is a
grave sin there's another say Hadith
mentioned in Sun Abu da ROM number three
in the book of maners Hadith number
4857 where a pleas with her the wife of
the Prophet she speaks about safia and
say that she is such a such thing
meaning she's short sted the prophet
immediately says that what you have said
if your words were mixed
in the sea it would spoil the full sea
further it's mentioned in Sun Abu da
volume number three in the book of
manners Hadith number 4860 where it's
mention anas pleas with him he says that
Prophet malli wasallam said when you
taken up to heaven that he saw some
people whose nails were made of copper
and they were scratching their faces and
the breast and when he ask that who are
these people the reply was these are the
people who back
bited indicating that backbiting is a
grave sin and it is one of the major
sins which people should abstain from
and many of us they do it
unknowingly not realizing that it's a
grave sin we should abtain from it and
the prophet also said if mentioned s
bukari Vol number eight in the book of
maners Hadith number
6056 a Monger he shall not enter
Paradise so this Hadi we come to know
that we have to be careful we should
guard our tongue especially from
backbiting and gossip ping